hi this is raphaël colantonio I'm the
president of arcane studios and creative
director on 'pray hey everybody this is
Ricardo Baer I am the lead designer on
'pray hurricane will of games that blend
simulation and narration like Dishonored
we do games you can play the way you
want pray is another one of those games
welcome to Talos 1 because of the
open-ended structure of the game the
player can go pretty much anywhere they
want on the station but right now our
mission is to find a scientist named dr.
Calvino some of our aliens turn into
things as a mean of camouflage
lots of ways to solve problems on Talos
one weapons are one of them but weapons
are rare okay so this is one of the most
important item in the game it's called
the neuro mod and this is how the player
upgrade himself so here is the RPG lay
of the game you could see this map
status inventory and these are the lists
of this is the list of abilities that we
have so some of them are human some of
them are aliens which you learn by
stabbing a needle into your eyes
[Music]
this is the glue cannon a tool that has
a lot of different uses this is an idiom
powered called super thermal we recently
acquired it's using the new mod okay so
we're gonna use the roster system in
order to try and track Calvino down but
the door's locked
so we're gonna take this opportunity to
demonstrate one of our unique alien
abilities called mimic so in the game
you can actually learn your powers from
the aliens so it's only fair that you
two can turn into a cup the roster
system helps players locate anyone
aboard Talos one
[Music]
the blue cannon can also be used for
traversal
[Music]
that was a phantom one of the other
kinds of aliens aboard the station and
this is a third way to use the Buchanan
so this item is called a recycler charge
in the game you can recycle pretty much
anything either to here declutter an
area or to use as a weapon now the
recycle elements that come out of it are
actually ingredients for fabrication
system that will show an ammonia aliens
aren't the only threat aboard tell us
one
mimic can be used on sofas tell
inventive players will be able to chain
powers together so right now this player
needs to get up onto that elevated
platform so they're going to combine
mimic with kinetic blast
okay so this is the fabrication system
so here are the ingredients I was
talking about earlier and this is the
fabricator so as long as you have
fabrication plans you can create any
object that is in the game
here we're creating an object to fly in
zero-g microgravity detected
[Music]
kalos one is a massive Space Station so
here we've modelled the entire exterior
which the player can use to chart their
course between missions or just where
exploration
[Music]
[Music]
not surprising well done
all right we've located our missing crew
member let's head back in okay now we're
going to see another ability that you
can great call leverage level three
which allows you to pick up huge objects
and use them as a weapon or just to
clear a path but players will have to be
careful sometimes installing alien neuro
mods because on occasion it will attract
the attention of other aliens
[Music]
and this is called a nightmare for a
reason and that's it for now thanks for
watching
Craig comes out spring 2017 on PC Xbox
one and PlayStation 4 bye
[Music]